police say Teen Mom 2 star Jenelle Evans
made up the story about her husband
shooting and killing their French
Bulldog nugget for publicity in a press
release from the Columbus County
Sheriff's Office in Whiteville North
Carolina police say Janelle contacted
them on April 29th and advised them that
her husband David Eason had shot their
dog after it bit their two-year-old
daughter Ansley in the face police
conducted a search of the couple's
property but found no blood or physical
evidence to validate the animal had been
fatally injured there when they
questioned Evans a day after the search
her account of the incident changed and
she said she no longer wanted to
continue with the investigation the
statement reads in part Jenelle's stated
that the reason she filed the animal
cruelty report was for the publicity and
because she did not know where her dog
was the Columbus County Sheriff's Office
has closed the investigation against
Eason and no charges will be filed in
this case where we gonna do as a result
of the incident Janelle was fired from
the MTV reality show
MTV have previously ended their
relationship with David in February 2018
after he posted a number of homophobic
and transphobic tweets